Треба рухатися швидко ми прямуємо на
передові позиції росіяни дуже близько
звідси
[музика]
[оплески]
військові кажуть що це одна з перших або
найперша позиція на цій ділянці лінії
фронту звідси до позиції де знаходяться
російські вороги приблизно 150 метрів ці
позиції знаходяться в південніше бахмута
але через певні природні перешкоди
ворогу дуже важко вести тут будь-який
наступ натомість збройні сутички та арт
обстріли тут постійно дістати може
будь-яка зброя
це росіяни стріляють у відповідь
відкриває вогонь для того щоб дізнатися
скільки нас тут де ми знаходимось солдат
за кулеметом зізнається що з кожним днем
відчуває все більший тиск Він каже що
ворог їх випробовує до чогось готується
це очищається з кожним днем все хуже
хуже і ймовірно ситуація буде
загострюватися найближчим часом
ви бачите що Весна Зараз досить суха
тому дуже зручно робити будь-які
наступальні дії для усіх тому йому вірно
ситуація загостриться в найближчі дні чи
тижні
і справа в тому хто і де буде їх
проводити весь цей час Вони намагаються
форсувати цей напрямок
ця продати російському народу взагалі
якусь перемогу
Тож вони ймовірно будуть тиснути у
найближчі дні
снайпери і мінометники становлять тут
постійну загрозу
тут нагинаєтесь
от ворожі позиції тільки обачно дивіться
пересуватися будь-куди небезпечно у
наступному бліндажі зустрічаємо чоловіка
з позивним таксист раніше він працював
на Алясці в США та спочатку
повномасштабної війни пішов до армії і
не бачив свою родину місяцями Вчора його
синові виповнилося 6 років ми запитали у
нього як він справляється тут на
передовій
страшно страшно
І ти думаєш про десятки тисяч загиблих
увечері з тобою курили цигарку і за
кілька годин їх немає
думаєш щодня думаєш
зважаючи на все це військові Тут будуть
продовжувати битися Бахмут який недалеко
звідси повинен вистояти кажуть військові
від самого бахмута йде дві стратегічно
важливих дороги всяких противник може
розвинути напрямки на будь-якому випадку
що одна із стратегічних об'єктів плюс у
них там зосереджено доволі велика
угрупування військ якщо прирують нашу
лінію оборони вони зможуть розвинути
дальше в глибину нашої країни
і для обох Бахмут залишається потужним
символом
що є
ворог гине а наш моральний дух високий
якщо вони настільки дурні що продати
перемогу захопивши Бахмут на початку
війни вони за три дні намагалися
захопити Київ Харків але Київ Стоїть
Харків стоїть а тепер намагається
продати Бахмут звідси можна зрозуміти як
насправді виглядає друга армія світу
проте критики стверджують що бахму
Т бігати ціни яку Україна платить
життями військові ж вважають по-іншому
не важливо чи то росіяни чи хтось інший
але вони прийшли на нашу землю це ворог
це окупант його треба знищити Його треба
вигнати звідси яку ціну платять українці
добре видно у цьому стабілізаційному
пункті Ми не можемо сказати Де ми
знаходимося але бої тут дуже близько ця
занедбана будівля нині польовий шпиталь
тут лікарі працюють цілодобово що
врятувати життя їхнє розташування в
небезпечній зоні є вирішальним поранених
привозять сюди прямо з передової і
стабілізують щоб вони могли пережити
дорогу до госпіталя цей чоловік отримав
осколкове поранення живота хірург Дмитро
зі своєю командою негайно береться за
нього через півгодини його вдається
стабілізувати для подальшого переміщення
щодня громада виконує тут до 80 операцій
за вас
останні випадки поранень це 90%
осколкових поранень від артилерії у
цьому місці у цьому стабілізаційному
пункті Ми також маємо багато кульових
поранень тому що війна ведеться в місті
і наш ворог використовує тісний контакт
з нашими солдатами тому в нас більше
випадків з кульовими пораненнями
це здебільшого осколкові ураження
найчастіше
[оплески]
найчастіше це кінцівка
бо вони у нас найменш захищені
[оплески]
набагато рідше це голова
десь відсотків може там
10-15 від загальної
[оплески]
велика кількість акубора травм Тобто це
внаслідок дії вибухової хвилі
тобто тут може не бути зовнішніх
пошкоджень тіла але при цьому тобто воно
може викликати і струси головного мозку
і за бою головного мозку може викликати
ну таке в найкращому випадку це буде
просто там розрив барабанної перетинки
Дмитро до повномасштабної війни керував
компанією з клінічних випробувань але
зараз він вирішив бути тут у кімнаті без
вікон де чути запах поранень і звуки
війни але Вони змінюють ситуацію каже
він
тебе бика ми стаємо більш професійними і
кожен з персоналу знає що йому чи їй
робити у цьому випадку Ми створюємо
деякі власні протоколи для допомоги
у медиків як і у військових тут немає
поняття робочого дня Це Зливається у дні
тижні і місяці медична рота це Не такий
вже і величезний підрозділ щоб хтось міг
собі дозволити там запланувати щоб
завтра я буду спати Ні у нас такого нема
у нас ну
всі працюють майже
цілодобово і
24 на 7 скільки годин він останній раз
стали сьогодні півтори години
вчора
напевно годину 4 чим ефективніший чи
вправніший ми працюємо нашому етапі тим
більше бійців
лишаються з мінімальними для себе
втратами і тим більше бійців можуть
повернутися і повернутися не тільки до
лав бойових підрозділів повернутись до
Цивільного життя абсолютно нормальним і
здоровими
[музика]
станція кра
маторг та дівчата їдуть в безпечне місце
а чоловіки повертаються на лінію фронту
ціна за Бахмут справді висока але
Україна готова платити